vingt ans après avoir mis les pieds en
afghanistan une conclusion chaotique et
précipité pour les alliés occidentaux
les vols d'évacuation tirent à leur fin
à kaboul une capitale dans la tourmente
le canada a mis fin à son opération
un choix déchirant
tech bol c'est
désespoir qui nous pourissent l'écho le
canada laisse derrière lui un nombre
indéterminé de citoyens canadiens et
d'afghans qui espéraient échapper aux
griffes des talibans au sein des forces
armées canadiennes un sentiment
d'impuissance et de culpabilité cet
autocar et de charger et émotion devient
précieux sont réouvertes pour certains
tandis que d'autres et on subit et
novell je reconnais à quel point
aujourd'hui c'est une journée difficile
pour bien du monde ce n'est pas la fin
de l'effort canadien promet justin
trudeau on va s'assurer de continuer
d'être là à pour mettre la pression sur
le tas l'hymne de son et aliments de
laisser les gens quitter l'afghanistan
qu'ils veulent il réitère son engagement
d'accueillir 20 mille réfugiés mais ce
programme vise des afghans qui ont déjà
fui le pays l'opération d'évacuation
canadiennes a trop tardé déplorent les
adversaires de justin trudeau monsieur
to do a manqué la prusse unités d'agir
sur la situation et d'agir sur les
réfugiés en danger et ses claques la
proche de justin trudeau n'était pas
suffisant et c'était une faillite et
maintenant on a beaucoup des gens qui
sont maintenant en péril en danger et ça
me rend tellement triste et combien des
interprètes qui se sont mis au service
bienveillant pour leurs populations
des forces canadiennes vont être
abandonnées derrière par le gouvernement
canadien le chef libéral se défend d
autres pays aussi ont été pris de court
les afghans les américains tous les
alliés on a tous été surpris par la
vitesse avec laquelle les talibans ont
pris le contrôle de kaboul est du pays
le dernier vol d'évacuation du canada
laisse dans son sillage un sentiment
d'échec et d'impuissance cette fin
mouvementée ne peut que rejaillir sur
justin trudeau puisque c'est lui qui
était aux commandes
demant il ya plusieurs mois quand les
américaines ont annoncé la date de leur
départ d'afghanistan ici louis blu-ray
radio canada ottawa